when did you decide you were going to
begin your own studio when I graduated
from Brooks Institute
I think 1975 believe it or not I was
fortunate enough to occupy a a rental
building that had a little teeny office
and from the very beginning of my career
I saw the advantages of having some kind
of exclusive place that I could go to
each day rather than work out of my
house and that extended over time into
me acquiring a studio and then it became
really a great part of the complexion of
my career is to have the tools available
24/7 versus waking up in the morning
producing a movie and renting everything
so I did what probably is not impossible
anymore but I started the acquire stuff
and save it and I did that through you
know all the years that I've been in
this business which has been quite a
substantial amount of years like 37 I've
been in the business doing television
and commercials for at least 20 and but
I've been in the field for 47 years 37
years yes okay so going back 37 years
what did you envision success to look
like versus what do you envision it now
because I know when someone starts a
venture they have all these grand ideas
about how life's going to be and what is
going to be like everyday to run a
business but then having been in the
trenches I'm sure seven days a week well
it's it's it's a very interesting
question because as I reflect back on my
career you know I was I'm one of the few
guys that actually has a left brain the
right brain where I'm a businessman and
I'm also a creative guy and that's an
unusual combination and ultimately I
knew from the very beginning that and
this is the same thing I tell my three
daughters you know if you're lucky
enough to find a career where you can do
what you love the money and all those
other things come later but they do come
and I started from scratch and little by
little I built a business
and one thing leads to another and then
finally I probably at the beginning of
the 80s I started doing what I called
hybrid filmmaking which means I would
not only do still photography I do
live-action and it became a category
that's now taken for granted because
everybody wants sound bites and
everybody wants beautiful visuals so now
you can theoretically do pulls off of a
red camera or the camera you're using
right now and they're usually 2k or 4k
and and you don't even need to bring in
a stuffed ographers so I was doing both
so what was the biggest surprise to
having run in business for over 37 years
you know the 80s were a much different
time than it is now social media was the
the whole thing is about reinventing
yourself it's funny as I was driving
into work this morning
you know I it became almost like an
epiphany in my own mind that I'm not
doing anything like what I was doing 10
years ago so I had to basically reinvent
myself and and as I look back in my
career that's all I've done throughout
my whole career is reinvent myself you
become a photographer is what I was for
many years and you all of a sudden wake
up in the morning and go oh my god I've
been working on this one client for four
years inevitably that's great for the
pocketbook but not much for the
advancements and what I want to be doing
creatively so you adapt and it's crazy
because I had one client from ABC that
told me you know why are you getting
that big studio on Hollywood I mean can
you can you really actually make a
living with that big studio and I and I
know this is total cliche but you know
if it's like the Kevin Costner statement
you build it and they will come and lock
down you know because at that time that
I built the studio which was at the end
of I feel around 1999 I built the studio
I found myself you know in a very unique
situation that I didn't even realize
which is most people were getting rid of
their Studios they were renting them so
I became a guy
actually had my own place and as crazy
as it sounds you know Roger Corman was a
little bit of that motivation and it was
also my desire to create a place where
the creativity could could grow so you
could sit outside and have a cigarette
or lunch and sit down next to a writer
or sit down next to a DP or you know
really take a position of of
collaborating and that was fun you know
did you have entrepreneurs in your
family did you see them not a single no
not a single terminal my dad was a sheep
medalist and my mom you know was a PTA
home housewife I have two siblings and
no I I just lucked out and had a passion
for what I did and I was able to sit
back and go how can I take then and
actually make more of it and just to
finish your first question which relates
directly to you know the formation of
setting up a business and and going
after what you want I'm currently on my
third film now and in this film here is
you know equates to being part of that
vision of working on meaningful projects
in this particular case this movie was
about a it's a romantic comedy but it's
also a pretty strong statement about
edible food and unedible food meaning
fast food and farm-to-table so I know
you'd sit in another interview that like
was it Richard Avedon and different
photographers were some of your idols
Francesco Scavullo I don't know you just
all the sort of these fashion
photographers so it seems like that was
your aim at one time to do that or
products and then well I went to when I
was going to to photography school you
know you pick mentors if you're
fortunate enough to be motivated by own
in my case I had Richard Avedon I had
Pete Turner and I had you know school Oh
Annie Leibovitz you know these are
people I looked at as being somebody I'd
like to be like and and when I finished
go I moved in New York and it became you
know almost dazed
rise to me to realize that well I think
I could make a living in LA I don't need
to live in New York you know and I knew
back then that lifestyle was more
important to me than money and I did not
want to you know leave my families my
friends so I came back to LA and
actually set up a business that way
because I'm sure the allure of doing a
Vogue cover you know so see when you're
just starting out is probably well it's
it's it's curious you say that because
as a photographer starting at the
beginning in my creative career you know
I did everything I did fashion I did
product shots I anything but a wedding
and and then you wake up one morning and
somebody gives you some advice you know
and that advice came at a high price I
paid a lot of money for somebody to give
me advice when I was in my 20s on how to
go to the next level and the advice came
with a question the question was very
simplistically you know what makes you
different from everybody else and and he
really screwed with me because he did
not want to tell me what the simplistic
answer was so I tried everything oh I do
great people shots I built great sets I
can motivate children I can and then he
said no no no no no think about it and
we'll talk next week and I was terrified
because I thought how could I be so
stupid he's asking me a question about
my own career and then finally spit out
I don't know I'm a problem solver and
the guy looks at me and I look at him
and he goes finally you know and that's
really you know kind of encompasses
everything about creativity how do you
you know make a documentary
you got to solve the problem how do you
make a in my case I I came across a
great idea for a TV show called the
cleaner based on personal experiences
and how do you sell it well you know you
wake up one morning you solve the
problem you know you got to figure out
in our case since I was half filmmaker
half photographer I started videotaping
the highlights with the person the real
person that the shows about it was the
first AMC drama that they made this is
way before Walking Dead and all this
other stuff and we were lucky enough to
have benjamin bratt as the star and the
character that he played on the TV show
was a gentleman that I knew in real life
so I filmed him multiple times talking
about what he did for a living and
condensed it into a 60-second piece and
that's how I sold the TV show and it
wasn't until you know six eight months
later when I'm working with the crew on
a pilot that they say do you know this
is like one in a million that you could
sell a show with no show success and
that's kind of the way I've run my whole
career is trying to focus on my goal
what is you know what is the the real
net choice that I'm gonna make am I
gonna make a movie about the circus or
I'm gonna make a movie about you know
somebody that goes out and saves people
from themselves and that's kind of why I
have a probably a portfolio visually of
different styles I'm always interested
in trying to grow well speaking of
growing so looking back on that mr.
Miyagi or whoever he was that were sort
of mentoring you do you ever think what
would have happened if you hadn't met
this person as frustrating as that
experience well a little bit it's this
person defined it's funny you can hire a
psychologist to come into your business
they're called business consultants they
come in they try to read your mind they
try to read what your goals are and they
try to help you understand how to get
there and the most basic thing is who
are you you know what do you really
offer and it's funny because as you
listen to other filmmakers talk listen
other writers talk you know it all comes
down to one thing and that is defining
what your goals are and Bethenny who's
my producer who brought in front of me a
opportunity to go to a a screenwriting
fest
in Hollywood that producers and writers
and are able to to meet and actually get
pitched one level it's a little bit like
one of those dating real-life dating
situations where they you got 30 seconds
to meet three minutes to meet somebody
and then the bell goes off and they
switch it's identical to that but each
time they're pitching you their movie
and immediately I said to Bethenny I
said I don't want to take any pitches
for science fiction I don't want to take
any pitches you know for comedies I
don't want to take any pitch I want
real-life stories and it helped define
my goal which is to find something that
I wanted to do rather than being
inundated with all these other forms and
I'm not critical of them it's just not
what I want to do your new comedy J off
the menu it's a romantic comedy set in
New Mexico based on food love different
things I want to hear more about that in
a little bit but I'm so curious about
how you met this screenwriter think you
said off camera it was that script
pipeline just like a screenplay sort of
meet-and-greet or something correct we
talked about like what it was like to go
there what your expectations were and
how it was to sit down with these
different screenwriters I'm gonna I'm
gonna help you here okay
when I set out to make my next movie
Bethenny my producer suggested we go to
screen screenwriters pipeline kind of
day in Hollywood where producers are
invited to meet screenwriters and it's
you know it sounds to me a little bit
like an overwhelming joke but it turned
out to be pretty fascinating as a
producer as well as a director to sit
face-to-face with screenwriters that
have busted their butts to you know
actually meet people and share their
hard work that actually could actually
make a decision on taking this project
to market I can tell you honestly the
screenwriters
no different than filmmakers you know
finding your next project is is hugely
challenging but we made a decision right
off the gate that we really didn't want
to take pitches from anybody unless they
were within the framework of something
that we wanted which was a story that
was gonna do the opposite of my last
movie my last movie girl on the edge
it's a very serious drama about a
real-life event and we didn't care about
whether it was real life now or not all
we cared about was we wanted to do
something that was inspirational
entertaining and we were lucky enough to
meet Jen Goldson the screenwriter of off
the menu at a writer's fest so to speak
in Hollywood where you meet writers and
you meet producers and you have an
ability to be able to be pitched these
properties and what's really cool about
it is you hear it from the person who
actually wrote the material and you hear
it very quickly I think they gave each
creative writer three minutes to pitch
their the screenplay
and you know it was one of the ones that
Bethany brought to my attention and we
read it and we liked it we thought we
could make this you know cool I mean one
of the big challenges of any type of
purchase of a screenplay besides
negotiating it is always going to be is
it even affordable to make because these
are independent movies and you know
maybe they're eighteen to twenty days
shoots so you have to have a
screenwriter that's not only willing to
sell their property but is also willing
to modify it or allow me to modify it
into something that is actually
something we can make because ultimately
in my movie off the menu
the screenwriter had written in a finale
where it was a hot air balloon being
chased by a truck and that itself might
have costed half of what the movie cost
although it was great writing it was
something that was unaffordable so we
were able to come to some you know
favorable solution yeah I was curious
about that so it's not only do you like
the material but also how much of a you
know mayor
is it really for that that time how
agreeable is the other person going to
be and vice versa you know it's a it's a
very important thing for me you know
filmmaking is a collaborative medium I'm
not a screenwriter although I'm
collaborating on screenplays all the
time that I'm trying to take the market
for myself but ultimately you wake up in
the morning and you really do come to
some real physical realities and that is
you know I don't think screenwriters
generally sit down and go this is a 1
million dollar movie this is a 50
million dollar movie they just write
from their heart and and I think it's
somewhat critical that in my life that I
have a good relationship with these
people because the last thing I want to
do is a ruin their movie and be you know
turn it into something that never was
supposed to be I mean I have a good
friend right now that bought a really
motivational big time movie you know
3040 million dollar movie and they shot
the movie and the editor started cutting
it to emphasize something that was never
intended and that's the way the movie
was finished so from my standpoint if
it's better that's great but if I was
the screenwriter I would be horrified
right and I want to go into that later
about any types of revisions while
you're on set and things like that but
what did Jennifer do right in her pitch
to you I think I think Jennifer did a
nice pitch enough to get Bethany to read
the script and then Bethany give me the
script but she writes with a really
believable pitch in her dialogue that
instantly found all of us engaged with
versus you know when I read scripts
sometimes it's painful because they're
writing in a zone that requires you to
get through ten pages before you start
to feel a sense of being a part to the
tone
of the screenplay and from from page one
I knew that it was going to be a quick
read and I think a lot of directors will
say the same thing about properties that
they've taken they just couldn't put it
down and this was you know that kind of
an experience having gone through the
experience meeting Jen going to this
pitch fest what advice could you give
other screenwriters on meeting a
filmmaker and pitching their script you
know it's no different than being a
photographer or a director you don't
have an opportunity to explain yourself
you see there on the page or it's not on
the page now if I had met Jen and she
was gone unquote difficult just at the
get-go I probably would have never even
read the script you know so I think
having a little bit of communication
skills as a gift in that regard I also
think you know stereotypically I'm not
I'm not like the stereotype I'm open to
collaborating and if you find out right
at the beginning that the person isn't
here's a great example a woman who
bethany again found me a wonderful
script about bigotry and the challenge
of working with skinheads and it was a
really really well-written movie it was
also a play and I had wished in
hindsight that I didn't spend an hour on
the phone with the writer when they said
all one thing I forgot to tell you is I
have to direct this myself so I felt you
know that that was something that should
come out in the first 10 seconds because
to me you know it's not uncommon for a
screenwriter to say I don't want anybody
else to direct this for me I only
produce movies that I direct and the
outcome of it is is that you know I've
learned that lesson that huh right so
then if that is a requirement or special
requirements like I want very little
edits done right get that out right away
I would
yeah I mean it's just not worth it
there's too many the the independent
film business is so convoluted with
waste and waste and then when you
finally get to execution here's a
wonderful example my other producer well
Newman who helped produce this movie he
was like you know the not just an
incredible collaborator to this movie
but he was the hatchet man in a positive
way he would come in and say no
disrespect to gems material but she's
got 56 characters and he knew right away
bingo that that was going to translate
into a portion of the budget that was
disproportionate with what we had and
what does that mean in English only
affordable amount of characters we could
have in his opinion was between 20 and
25 characters and I know that sounds
crazy but any independent filmmakers
gonna come in front of the same moment
that I came in front of when you go do
you really need that character to walk
in the door go hey you got a phone call
that character is a SAG talking actor
and that's gonna cost you X amount of
dollars and you put 40 more of those in
the movie and you've made a movie that
you're not gonna be able to afford and
it's crazy and you know I know that
you're interviewing me about creativity
but if you can get this stuff off the
table before you start talking
creativity you'll have you know in my
opinion a more controllable project once
Jennifer Goldson got you the script to
read how much time passed before you
finally read it and then finally said
okay to it that's a wonderful question
because I don't think that Bethenny and
Joe Gamache is one of my other producers
and will even could have believed that I
believe we bought the property in like
October and we were in pre-production in
January and we shot the movie and August
or September or something it's just
unheard of but you know that's the way I
work and the outcome of it is at this
rate we can produce a movie every couple
years and in success use the the
moderate success of
these movies to finance the next movie
are you okay with talking about what the
next steps were once you all agreed that
we really love this film and we think we
can do it for a reasonable budget what
were some of the next things you did to
actually secure the deal
well once we made a deal with the
screenwriter you you basically option
the script you pay a certain amount of
money and thus that gives you the
comfort of writing the script modifying
the script and then actually making the
decision to greenlight it that happened
in just a few months for me on this
movie versus buying a script off the
shelf spending two years in
pre-production and then actually going
out and shooting it there's so many
there's so much equity in experience
here because first-timers including
myself you make a lot of mistakes and I
just mentioned one of them I mean we
just got a bill for the last movie from
sag that was unaffordable and the movie
hasn't even I don't know what I don't
want to complain about it but the movie
hasn't even you know broken even and
we're getting bills from sag for
residuals and the movie never came out
of theaters I'm not complaining right
now what I'm trying to say is I'd never
anticipated that so for my next film
I'll have to put away funds rather than
having to borrow funds in order to pay
for the my last movie saying because the
way the financials work in independent
filmmaking if you're lucky enough to get
a distributor and I mean that honestly
because there's so much of a flood of
independent filmmaking now if you're and
lucky enough to get an independent
distributor you have one thing conquered
but what you don't have is the concept
of how Hollywood works you know first
you're the last person to get paid and
then in itself is troubling because I
financed the movie myself I can't even
conceptualize what it must feel like and
I do know somebody recently who made a
movie
I believe Netflix wanted to buy for a
substantial amount of money and but not
enough to break even and and the
filmmaker had no choice in the matter
because he was a hired hand even though
he directed the movie and produced it
all the money was borrowed and he really
you know had to acquiesce to the sale
and the I don't think the movie has ever
broken even and he doesn't even talk to
the people that he borrowed the money
from and this is not a negative or a
positive it's just an observation of
just how you know perception reality I
had a guy yesterday tell me wow your
movie just came out yesterday it came
out and he goes are you gonna buy a new
house you read People magazine yeah and
I don't mean that as a joke because it's
the first thing you see in the news Star
Wars made X amount of money no one
including myself has any context to
understanding what that means and the
outcome of it is is that you know I
think it's pretty critical to understand
that the business is changing my last
film in this film it's totally different
we didn't have a distributor when we did
the first movie we have a sales rep and
then he interns sold at the Fox he
interns sold it to Sony domestically and
it's not a question of good or bad it's
just a question of understanding and
this time around rather than sell it
internationally first we did what most
people do which I didn't know we sold
domestically first you know and now
we're selling Europe and all the other
territories so we're doing it probably a
much better way now than we did the
first time wanted to go back to what you
said about putting away reserves you
know I've heard this with people that
have business issues with payroll taxes
different things I don't think people
realize the the value of reserves or
saving yourself
well I'll kill two birds with one stone
here because I know you're gonna talk
about tax credits and I also talked
about the question you just asked me I
don't think you can ever really be too
prepared
for how much money this stuff all costs
it is an extraordinary thing that I made
two movies now with a non-union crew am
i bragging about it not at all but it
made me afford to do the movie I
couldn't have done the movie my first
movie if it was a sanctioned Union movie
this is independent filmmaking you know
when you I just saw a movie the other
night that was all shot on an iPhone of
people traveling from from Syria to to
Berlin at a film festival is brilliant
all shot on an iPhone and and I'm sure
it's all his family members so he
doesn't have the burden of the stuff I'm
talking about I actually make movies and
I'm a signature to sag
so I want the best talent I can get to
make these movies but with that comes a
lot of little surprises you know and
they're not surprises by deception
they're just ignorance and as a
filmmaker and a producer yeah I am and
as the world changes you know month
leaking in in this business I can tell
you right now most distributors that
distribute independent properties that
existed three years ago half um don't
exist anymore because it's just not the
business models changed and when I made
my last movie DVDs were actually an
interesting proposition now it's a
fragment so constantly it's changing
let's talk about the music and off the
menu you have a composer that you hired
yeah gentleman by the name of Dave
Holden was the composer of both my films
grow on the edge in this recent film off
the menu and my experience in working
with him and collaborating with him has
been magnificent one of the things you
learn in independent filmmaking is after
your burned out making the movie you get
to an editing room and you start putting
staples that are or examples that are
available to that alert of stick in for
for cutting purposes but you could never
afford to buy and in this particular
case my first movie and this movie Dave
mandated if I wanted to work with him I
had to be used original musicians that
essentially encompass the entire score
of the film and I was I used to be a
musician and for me that was just too
good to be true but along with that
comes you know just a burden for the
filmmaker and for the composer because
everybody wants magic and all the other
composers that we interviewed for the
movie were were all going to do it on a
synthesizer you know he goes you won't
even tell differencing the violins you
know you won't be able to tell the
difference you know with the scale of
the orchestra it'll just be totally
believable and that's true but when you
bring in live musicians there's just
something that happens especially if
they're scoring it to picture and that's
what we did we were very lucky to bring
in some of the best musicians in Los
Angeles and and then double them and
make them look you know the a 16-piece
orchestra sound like a 60-piece
orchestra yeah it's an interesting
question about the fundamentals of
putting music in a movie because movies
require you to you have a number of
avenues you could you could buy stock
music needle drop is what it's called
and usually very affordable and in and
you can pay extra to have it for life
and you know what your burden is and
since you're speaking to not just the
director but the producer I'm gonna tell
you that that is a huge surprise to a
lot of filmmakers because they get up in
the morning and ago I gotta have that
track from the Rolling Stones because
the movies about this and they got a
song about this and that was part of my
pitch when I told my investors and then
he goes about trying to get the song in
the song he might get a great deal on
the song you might pay I'm making this
up right now
50 grand for that song I'm talking about
because the filmmakers have a rapport
with the manager of the band or what
have you the problem is those songs that
they're buying all are licensed which
means come up a year they got a re divvy
up funds and I know a filmmaker you know
that made that mistake and put in a at
least six songs in his movie that are
already established songs but his not
annually is about a hundred seventy five
grand
whether the movie makes money or not
he's got to pay it and one of the
luxuries I had is the the composer not
only was passionate enough to want to be
a part of this project but he saw a life
at the other end where he could resell
the music and make it up there and it's
turned into a very profitable thing
actually more profitable for him than me
because he can license new music to
anybody sorry to play the devil's
advocate here but wouldn't the contract
say that he was purchasing it for this
amount in perpetuity or wouldn't there
be a time frame when he would need to
renew or say well this producer and
director who shall renamed nameless it
doesn't really you know he's not an
attorney and and he is so elated to get
the music he probably I can only
speculate you know just like me I'm not
reading the fine print and the outcome
of it is is that he woke up in the
morning just with with a huge smack in
the face of something that he never
anticipated and to me like I mentioned
earlier you know with my last film I was
never expecting to get a bill from sag I
thought I'd pay to all the people and
the movie hadn't even made half its
money back why am I getting billed for
residuals and ignorance you can call me
a total dope but I never was educated on
that component so I had to pull that
money which was over 20 grand out of my
own pocket because the funds just simply
aren't there and I learned a huge lesson
so now to your point I will put in my
budget in
a certain amount of money aside for that
12 months later moment where you got to
go hey I got to pay everybody you know
another example is is just understanding
what you can't do and what you can do
and this goes to music this what goes to
sag actors and this goes to getting
excited about doing a special screening
and not knowing the rules because if you
take in money that takes you to a
different level and forgive me for
asking it in that way but I and I
wouldn't have known that either
I wouldn't know that you would need to
renew I mean a licensing fee or
something you'd be on the hook for
another year and well with music you you
know this is very interesting great
question because I believe and I'm sure
that what I'm suggesting happens all the
time
is you sell your movie to let's just say
hypothetically it's really well received
at Sundance you sell your movie to to a
big you know five star distribution
company and they go and recut it and
pull those expensive songs out because
they want to make money or conversely
the filmmaker pulls them out so his film
becomes more sellable interesting and I
have a friend who actually my first
screening around on my first movie he
sold his movie at Sundance and it was
called Blue Valentine oh and his name's
Joey Curtis a very nice guy he co-wrote
that movie but in his case his next film
was was everybody's looking forward to
it because his name was equated with a
movie that won at Sundance and the
outcome OVA was is the person that
bought his next movie gave him an extra
half million dollars to sweeten the pie
put in better music better sound effects
so that also happens as well that's
that's a goldmine in that case right
great to know yeah just all these little
surprises that you wouldn't expect and
you don't want to get that email on
Monday morning III think you know the
film business is
a complicated business and you know you
read in the papers about bad blood
between distributors and filmmakers on
very very successful movies and you know
you see that I'm just making this up
that the guy who wrote a film that won
for you know four Oscars is still hasn't
made one royalty yet but meanwhile you
know everybody else got their hands out
yeah and it's creative financing
what-have-you but you know that doesn't
even affect me now because I'm not even
involved in that but it is something you
got to educate yourself
I had one filmmaker say to me that they
made sort of a $250,000 reel for
themselves that's what they considered
it at the end of the day and it became a
calling card and then it led to other
things but they were surprised too well
I think we all make movies as filmmakers
to help identify our next endeavor and
and in you project a positive review you
project a positive in some cases
financial success people are more
attracted to you that's why I found it
interesting in an earlier part of this
conversation where I said screenwriters
write great pieces but they insist on
directing it themselves when in my mind
if you're an unknown you're more likely
not going to see that as a positive
conclusion because who would put their
money into a director that's never made
a movie before how often are you looking
for scripts to purchase constantly
what's your process where are you
looking I'm looking right now for a
script for my next movie and working on
ideas at the same time we've had some
bumps in the road I tried to option a
book and we got very excited about it
and it turned out that the book was
entangled in another country even though
the rights had run out the other country
had
tax credit for the film and gave them
advance funds which I didn't know this
but legally terminate any kind of future
purchase because the money is already in
play wow I never knew that
it's fascinating information because I
would never think that either you just
these are all things that I don't think
the writer of the book knew that either
yeah Wow so so once you found out that
that's probably a no-go at least for now
we go what's a week ago okay the how do
you kind of get back on the horse and
start looking for started immediately
you know a filmmaker typically doesn't
have just one project that he's
interested in doing in my case I have a
pretty important mandate I'm only
looking to do projects that are
personally beneficial to the world and
I'm not talking about pollution or
something like that I'm talking about a
meaningful project that that would help
people engage and and and see things
filmmaking is so brilliant I just saw a
great movie I can mention it called the
insult and it is it's a masterpiece why
is it a masterpiece go see the movie and
you understand because it talks about
you know it didn't matter that it was
filmed in Lebanon what mattered to me
was it could have been anywhere and
whether you're talking positive about
politics or negative it could have
happened anywhere and it was not a true
story it was fiction but the way it was
filmed in the way it was written really
tells a great story about tolerance and
talks about hatred and when when you see
a film like that and you walk out you
you're you're affected in a way almost
Shakespearean and that's the kind of
films that I want to make films that
viscerally help you understand the world
more and maybe make you more tolerant
maybe make you more perceptive and you
know certainly filmmaking is one of the
best vehicles other than speech and to
me
or book filmmaker you know really has an
opportunity to tell story and with the
the belief not in purposeful preaching
but the belief is you'll walk out and
you'll have a perspective you might
never have had I think that you've said
before that you don't use a lot of
nudity or swearing like vulgar language
in your films why is that I don't think
it's it's very interesting whenever I
hear a story about a crazy actor or a
crazy filmmaker or or a movie that does
something outlandish you know the first
thing I think of as a filmmaker got
could I have asked that actor to do that
or you know I just read an article about
Tarantino having to strangle Huma
Thurman and he chose to do it himself
and I don't have an opinion of that the
only thing I can say to you is is I
don't think I would have done that but I
don't make Pulp Fiction
you know and this is not a derogatory
this is actually a statement about the
depths of being a a filmmaker because
during my movie that I just made there
was a number of times you could say what
if the kid drowned you know what what if
somebody choked on the food what if they
can go what if until the cows come home
but the outcome of it is is that I don't
think language even though I swear a lot
I don't think language it doesn't I
don't think a character needs to swear
if it's written properly and it doesn't
even have to be come out of his mouth
it's his physical actions I'm not
opposed to using bad language in a movie
I'm just saying to you that just so
happens in my first movie girl on the
edge I'm going to tell you that since
it's a movie that's biographical and I'm
part of it
I was freely open to say I'm gonna say
exactly what I said and the movie
exposes a parent and I was the father
played by Gil bellows and you know I
think it was important to be honest and
truthful
and I got a lot of because people
thought that the language which was the
f-word was used too much but when when
your own child gets raped and you're
trying to condole can console her or
help her understand the position she put
herself in you say things that can't
believe came out of your mouth and we
consciously the screenwriter who Joe
Gamache who predominately wrote that
movie will say to you unequivocally that
Jay you keep mentioning it this is what
happened you know I wanted to be
truthful so in and if you read the
reviews on Amazon about girl on the edge
there are people that have said the
language was was intense and that's why
I used it because it's truthful I'm sure
anyone who's a parent there there was
writing in my script that I just did
that I just said there's no reason to
use that word let's just tell him in a
screw-off you know can we go back to the
negotiation process of securing the
script with Jennifer how did that go
once you say yes I think before and I'm
not gonna talk money but I think before
you even start this conversation I think
it really is appealing to me that the
filmmaker wants to make the movie as
much as the screenwriter wants to
filmmaker to make the movie I think it's
almost a prerequisite it's kind of like
throughout my 37 years in my own
business here I've always made it a
prerequisite to say to whoever I am
about to employ that in as much as you
know I'd love for you to take the job
you know I would like to tell you that
the feelings are mutual you know because
if you don't want the job but you want
eat like the the employment I'm really
not interested in you you know because
it's about growing and to me when a
filmmaker secures a script and
negotiates a deal I think most of that
is predicated on the screenwriters
ability to actually look
at it as an investment in themselves
when I was trying to negotiate my
current book deal for this book I was
trying to buy you know I had had
multiple conversations with the author
of the book about my vision but because
of my experience
it also included real reality
conversations about the kind of budgets
I work in and the commitments that I
make and I'm one of the few people that
can sit here and talk to you and say I
do what I say I'm gonna do and Jennifer
knew that you know she'll only get a
fragment of what I have to pay her until
production starts and once production
starts it triggers the at least I think
it triggers a 50 or 70 percent advance
on what she's supposed to get paid and
typically when ends up happening is is
you know most scripts are bought and
they're never produced and I think what
was appealing to her is her first movie
was gonna get written I mean was going
to get made and that to her was
invaluable and currently the book that I
just tried to buy it was a situation
where the control was removed and it's
incredibly important to me because when
you're making independent films
screenwriters saying they're holding out
for the big bucks
our screenwriters holding out for a
certain director or as I mentioned
before screenwriter actually holding out
so they can direct it themselves these
are all self induced obstacles that
they're creating for themselves and I
think it all comes down to I'm gonna get
a film made and how many screenwriters
I've got friends that are incredibly
successful screenwriters that have never
gotten one of their movies produced but
they're writing movies firk
big you know Hollywood movies and they
just never make it to the screen and to
any screenwriter that's very common
from a filemaker standpoint I think you
know the the concept of actually taking
a screenplay buying it and putting it in
production is a rare thing very rare so
that to me is quote-unquote an
enticement so then going into production
triggered and execution of severa you
then what no longer becomes an option of
a script it becomes actual it's in
production okay so then you have your
duty to to give for the money for that
and then what rights does the
screenwriter usually have when it comes
to changing and it's all negotiable in
in number one you know I think every
filmmaker that's doing movies like I'm
doing independent films is really not
interested in exploiting the
screenwriter oh right so she in my case
retained rights for a TV series in and
she also you know has an ability to make
sequels and so forth and so on you know
you have these concepts that are that
are pre described that make it enticing
but if you do it and I know Jen well
enough now to say she wouldn't be heard
if I said this it was never about the
money it was about getting your property
actually made right and so was she ever
on set with you well we invited her to
the set at the end and in all honesty no
disrespect to her but there's such an
enormous amount of pressure to get a
movie made and especially independent
movies you're working on such issue
you're shooting is 27:35 scenes a day
and the last thing I wanted to do was
have someone sitting behind me that is
questioning the tone or what-have-you
she trusted me and when we finally got
her kind of positive greenlight we let
her come more you know but it was not
personal it had it had to do with
actually my own insecurities well I mean
when even doing film courage I wouldn't
want someone except David sitting behind
me telling me don't
you know what I'm saying like it's
different if it's you and I talking
about
but I don't think that's unreasonable at
all right especially if you have all
that money on you know the thing is is I
lucked out on this movie off the menu
because number one I hired two leads
there were total professionals they had
already had significant amount of
success Danya had a movie called well
she was on The Sopranos she was also on
heroes on TV she was also she's
currently on once upon a time and then
you've got Santino Fontana who
essentially he's was one of the leads in
the animation film called frozen and
he's a lead on a crazy ex-girlfriend so
these guys I'm not gonna tell how to do
comedy right and and as a matter of fact
as a filmmaker you know it's I encourage
improvising and a lot of the stuff that
they took they made better and I don't
have any complaints whatsoever so I'm
very fortunate in the entire cast of
this movie you can't make independent
movies with amateur actors you just
can't do it because typically when ends
up happening is they will cost you you
know two three times what you expected
because you can't get through the day
you're held up it's not a it's not a lie
that you know in my case this I would
always do two takes but in many cases
filmmakers on independent movies don't
II do one tank
it's the Clint Eastwood model what is it
like for you on set trying to make your
day how bound are you by the hour the
minute
number one I'm the executive producer of
this movie and I'm also the director and
I think it's super critical that
boundaries are set right away and
in the case of well Newman with my
producer he personally was responsible
for you know in advance in
pre-production scheduling my day along
with the DP and Matt Edwards who was the
DP of the movie is really the most
important person on the set because if
he slows down or can't make the day that
he previously agreed to you know this
has a incredibly dark story at the end
of the day because the next day you've
got a whole nother list of things and
what made will such an asset to our
movie you know and then again also a
Matt an incredible asset is your ability
to be honest with yourself you know and
I mentioned earlier that the
screenwriter had a beautiful third act
where the hot-air balloons were being
chased by a truck and the actors were
hanging out of the truck and hanging out
of the balloon and I mean there's just
no way we could have done that in even
in an economical way in less than a day
versus the way we ended up doing it is
in less than a half a day on the Rio
Grande
that was our creative solution that the
screenwriter agreed to and you know if
she didn't agree to it we would have
come up with something else but the
outcome of it is we collaborated on it
and as a producer and a director it was
my goal to make the day every day and I
think we made the day every day but one
day and the reason we didn't make it
that day was something something that
was unexpected happen and it happens all
the time in the business I mean one of
the the real tragedies of doing
independent filmmaking is is is you know
things that you can't control
so my movie takes place predominantly in
Taos New Mexico and in LA and I made a
significantly smart decision to build a
a kitchen here on my stage that we could
flick a switch each day and modify the
lighting but never have to worry about
the Sun going behind the building next
door never have to worry about going
into overtime and and this no alight at
all
it gave us an ability to do probably two
times more work on the stage than we
would have done in New Mexico at a real
restaurant and most importantly
creatively I was able to you know work
with the set designer and create
something that I feel was one of the
most magical parts in the movie is her
domain her restaurant her her dining
room and all that was made on my stage
what's your formula or process for
telling a good story you know this is a
really great question I think that
storytelling you know I am NOT a verbal
person I am a visual person and you
constantly if you're Steven Spielberg
self-edit before you even go out on a
stage you know go on on the location you
already know what you want Bing Bing
Bing Bing if you're really fortunate I
think and I always used to say this when
I was doing commercials you know Ridley
Scott builds 180 foot wide set and when
the when the scenes over with you look
at and they only use 12 feet of it you
know he's got that luxury an independent
filmmaking you don't have that luxury
and in quite frankly you you have to be
intuitive enough to recognize what your
your quest is and then storytelling you
know it is is that scene really
necessary where the little girl goes and
knocks on the door and says you know hey
you want to come out and play can we
just cut to her you know already there
and and then you start self editing and
typically this is motivated by your
desire to keep the story intact but be
inventive
and we had to do that all the time you
know and and I think especially having
even though Jen wrote the script Joe
Gamache who is one of the producers is
also a writer and he was able to on the
fly help us simplify scenes you know
that were sometimes over complicated and
I'm not talking about the writing I'm
talking about having to shoot it from
six angles and it's interesting cuz when
you read or hear interviews like you're
doing on me from great filmmakers
typically especially someone like Clint
Eastwood will actually talk about the
fact that why'd that scene only come
from one point of view and he goes
that's how I need it and and even the
actors complained they wanted to don't I
get a close-up you know and and I
thought to myself it's it's it's it's
Clint Eastwood's got a lot of balls you
know to be able to wake up in the
morning and just say no you know and
it's it's so funny because I'm always
fascinated about reading about back
stories about other filmmakers and you
know it takes a lot of guts
and a lot of self confident to take the
most dramatic scene in your movie my
last film girl on the edge there's a
very climatic dramatic moment where
Peter Coyote is talking to Taylor Sprite
leur the star of the film and it's a
very serious moment and we just
organically felt this isn't going to be
covered in and we all handheld and we'll
do it from a couple moves on the fly but
we will not do new setup so we'll just
keep filming and that works for me you
know and it worked for the film because
from an editorial standpoint you're not
putting together five angles of emotions
that are drifting you know one moment
you might feel it's great to talk about
this and get close and the next take you
might not and and that's I think actors
appreciate that giving them the freedom
to bring out storytelling in a way that
is more
coming from their hearts how much time
did you spend developing the script
before pre-production in the movie that
I just made off the menu the the
pre-production period was around six
months it really became a legitimate
pre-production three months before
meaning we hire on some of the
department heads and we start actually
actively pre-production but I called
pre-production the minute that the
producers start working on you know
managing our days managing our equipment
managing our location time I mean I
started scouting locations six months
before we started shooting did you set a
production date before the script was
ready that's a real important question
because ultimately there are so many
factors than enter the game we had
another actor a lead that pulled out I
think three weeks before we went into
production and that's always a big fear
because I don't care how much you think
you're paying them is good it's never
even close to a legitimate film and the
actor that we had hired for both my last
movie and this movies fell out not
because they didn't want the project but
because they got a huge project and one
of them I believe was a transformer
scene I mean so how do you compete with
that you know but when you finally it's
very interesting because you'll find
that most independent films are casted
literally days before the film actually
goes into production because of this
problem and no disrespect to the agents
but why would the agent take a you know
a small independent movie over
transformers you know his business model
is to get as much business as he can for
the actor that's why it's important to
hire actors that really want to do this
movie which we were lucky enough to have
and then if you're lucky enough to get
someone like Peter Coyote in a movie you
know you're even more vibrantly
walking down a road of just total luck
great luck I know you mentioned
previously about an actor dropping out
getting cast in something huge that the
last minute aside from that and I know
that's a huge thing what was one of the
other biggest challenges you faced in
pre-production and how did you work
through it
yeah it's very interesting Bethenny and
will my producers who came in right at
the beginning of the film you know we're
tackling a monumental task for very
little money so you have to be smart you
have to be intuitive and of course you
have to look at the clock and go hey if
we start pre-production meaning we bring
in set designers we bring in department
heads you know we need to do that I'm
making this up six weeks to eight weeks
before we actually start day one and all
of a sudden it became very clear to me
that and they became very clear to them
that there was so much to do especially
because we were we my Studios in
Hollywood and the movie split between
Hollywood and New Mexico you you arise
to the realities that weather is going
to be a problem you arise to the reality
of tax credits you will you you actually
wake up in a almost a splash of water in
your face two complexities that you
would have never even thought of such as
in our case in the finality of the movie
the actress almost drowns in the Rio
Grande and check this out you know four
weeks before production we went and
scouted for a what they call tech Scout
with the DP and with the gaffer and grip
and we and we were excited but we were
conceptually flabbergasted by the fact
that because of the drought the Rio
Grande they had lowered probably five
inches from what it was when I went five
weeks earlier and then of course m'as
predicted that it was continued to go
down and there was a time where we
wondered perhaps
we're not even going to be able to shoot
on the Rio Grande because it's it's just
not enough water in it
and it's one of the only things that I
had to vie for when I finished the movie
was have the finale the grand finale of
the movie digital effects put in to make
it look more dangerous because the
actors were literally working in four
feet of water as submerged it just
enough for their their butt to clear the
water line and you know it worked
there's you know there's no giveaway
there but who would have ever imagined
that it would have gone down three feet
by the time I sort of two months earlier
that it was and it all had to do with
the drought and the reality is it was
cold you know so all these things
combined and we had safety issues you
know we had to hire people to be down
the river to catch him god forbid that
something cut loose we had to bring in
stunt people from Albuquerque and to
play the little girl and also to do
stunts you know for the for the major
actor because he rides a bike and flips
off you know all the stuff looks real
easy that when you get out there to do
it the quick towel in my opinion is when
you wake up in the morning and somebody
says like me like Tarantino did to uma
thurman you can ride the car shouldn't
be any problem at all well the truth of
it is in my case you know add the same
same kind of challenges that every
filmmaker has should this be something
that the stuntman does or is the actor
agile enough to just you know to jump
off the bike himself and everybody
convinced me it's worth paying for you
know a stuntman even though the actor
was willing to do it and the big
advantage that really is truthful in the
conclusion is that a nobody got hurt and
B we did it in one take so you know it's
there's a scene in my movie where the
little girl is driving a pickup truck
into the Rio Grande how do you go about
setting a shot up like that on a little
budget movie and you know that was a
challenge and how long is that going to
take and you know how could we cheat it
you know can we can we make it and we
ended up cheating it we ended up
bringing in water guns and have her
stopped before she got into the lake
shot off the water guns and then changed
the angle so it looked like well the
truck was already in the water you know
so it's I mean and here again none of
this stuff came directly from me it's a
collaboration I think was critical to be
an inventive filmmaker you got to just
drop your ego at the door and you got to
know there's a reason why somebody like
will Newman who was my producer and I
believe today today critical schedules
that he set with AD and Bethenny who is
also the producer on the movie and
taking care of many of the things that
are day-to-day that I know I'm not
burdened with but I will tell you that
surrounding yourself by competent people
even though I'm a photographer and I
know how to light and I know what I want
I let the DP tell the story it's all his
sure I said I'd like to shoot this way
or sure I said let's can we backlight it
or complements but generally speaking
you know anything that I'm burdened with
that's above and beyond storytelling is
gonna be shown in the movie you know so
if I'm worried about if someone's going
to break their their neck riding a bike
you know that is gonna burden my ability
to do my job so I think it's really
critical and this this covers every
medium camerawork it covers storytelling
from the script it covers your ability
to be able to trust the actors with with
the material you know there's a number
of times on this movie where I you know
we're shooting it totally out of
continuity and I had to talk to the
actress not in a negative way but this
is your strength doesn't come yet even
though you know you're going there I
want to wait I want it to build slowly
and she understood immediately but you
know self editing a movie in advance
that's shot out of continuity is a test
can't even describe and incidentally I'm
trusting the wardrobe department I'm
trusting hair and makeup because you
know they look different in every scene
and even though I'm shooting this way
for you know two pages and then moving
the actors this way and something that
takes place 70 minutes later you need to
have confident people around you that
are following continuity that are
following in the the tone of the movie
and all the little details is what makes
I think it's possible to produce
independent movies but I'm the first one
to tell you each time I do one I feel
more and more comfortable because I'm
trying not to make the same kind of
errors that I did on other movies you
have this amazing studio here in the
heart of Hollywood why choose New Mexico
it's interesting I wanted to get out of
the studio number one and number two
there's a short of shooting on the back
lot of Universal or taking a grabbing a
piece of the San Fernando mission
there's just no place to go that you can
get the kind of versatility you can and
with the tax credit that you receive as
a filmmaker which incidentally in New
Mexico was extraordinary and I'm not
just talking financial I'm talking
support they did so much for us and in a
way that filmmakers would want to
embrace I'd be I'd be their biggest
pitchman because never once did we fell
Bandhan and it's a deadly shooting in
Taos is like living here in LA in
shooting up in the mountains you know
it's it's two and a half hours outside
of Albuquerque so no matter what you
want it's going to be a pain in the ass
and they helped us in a way that was not
only generous but unexpected was that
the plan all along to shoot into me I
mean it looks absolutely beautiful makes
me want to go there and really but I
mean was that the plan all along or did
you look at some of the tax credits look
at some of we looked at everything if
you see the movie you will analytically
you will see that the travels to get to
new
go took us to shoot in Lancaster but you
won't know it's Lancaster you'll just
know that it's the same desert and those
decisions were entirely economic we had
I think 20 extras and the principal's
were here in LA but and we lost two and
a half hours of our day to get there and
two and Afra days to get back but we
were able to shoot you know I think at
least the day less here than in New
Mexico but when we got to New Mexico you
know we were anticipating you know
having a very very productive days but
every night we would get back and we
would have post-production meetings
going what if it rains every day because
you know if you don't have cover sets to
go to you're just throwing your money
away and I know you just come off a
rainy spell where you got yeah we lucked
out because it rained literally up to a
day before we started shooting in fact
we had to make allowances for mud and it
did not rain again for 19 days Wow it
was a total blessing from God you know
and then when you get done with a
scenario like that and it starts pouring
and I'm talking to you cats and dogs you
realize just how screwed we would have
been there was one day as one day before
we're in shooting where it there was
lightning and I didn't know this talk
about ignorance you know the ad came
right up to me and said were shot down
and I'm going why the lightnings 20
miles away and he goes we're shut down
and he looked at me straight I and he
goes don't question me you know I'm not
putting the the the crew or the cast in
jeopardy and all the mobile homes with
the talent had to turn off their engines
you know because God forbid they get hit
they don't want to have an arc and that
was the same day that when I called rap
at seven o'clock at night 702 it started
raining and the density of the rain was
so fierce that it would have
it would it would have just been
miraculous we've been able to finish the
movie
and by the way I just want to mention
something is the actors had other
commitments the crew had other
commitments there was just no way to go
in two more days unlike a big you know
Hollywood movie when you have that kind
of flexibility what advice do you have -
first time second time filmmakers on
seeking a distribution deal and then
actually committing to it is a tough
question for me because every time you
make a deal you learn about new deals
I'll give you an illustration when I
made my first movie we didn't have
people knocking on her door to
distribute my movie we had sales reps I
never even knew what that was but
there's a lot of companies in LA in
Hollywood that are sales rep they rep
and they would take your movie to
Netflix and they would take your movie
to Fox and they would make deals and I
totally believe in that scenario never
even occurred to me you know that my
next movie would be good enough for
someone to go we want to distribute it
of course there's no money exchanged you
know you have to wait get the movie
distributed and then eventually make
your money back but if you're lucky
enough to hypothetically wake up in the
morning and Sundance and somebody buys
your movie to distribute it they might
say we'll give you X dollars not to
mention the fact that after advertising
dollars are spent we'll give you 50
cents on the dollar you know whatever it
might be I did not have that luxury but
I did have the luxury this time of
getting a reputable distribution company
and taking it up a notch so each time
you I learned more but distribution and
I'm saying this redundant ly because I
said it before is an ever-changing
medium and you know I'm learning right
as we speak that you know filmmakers are
expected to do things that have then do
with filmmaking
and that is if you really want to
succeed with your movie social media has
to be played you have to do self
marketing yourself you got to do
interviews like this and I'm really
grateful but you know I'm not a social
media guy you know and but you have to
learn how to do that
and it's fascinating to me because I
have a number I don't know on my
facebook I got a number of people that
are filmmakers so everyone so I see a
filmmaker promoting their movie and you
know I'm empathetic because it requires
just an inordinate amount of collective
collaboration with the distributor to
succeed because they're making
distributor picked up my movies making
it puts out four movies a month as 48
movie that's a lot of movies for a small
company and one of the ones I passed on
did 30 or 40 movies a month and they're
into the volume aspect so I felt that
the one that I picked was more desirable
because they would give it more energy
and more time and I don't have a regret
for that but here again I'm speaking
from first-time experience I met a
gentleman just last week who's doing our
social media and he's also a director
and a smart guy young guy and you know
he I think if I was able to tell him
what I learned now on his first movie he
would have done something differently
and it's not like he made a horrific
mistake but he ultimately took his movie
off the market you know and that is
there are other ways to do it no
different than the woman he told me that
on my new fib film you know my last
movie wasn't ever exploited on social
media and the content matter itself
should have been an easy pitch but we
didn't do it so is it a missed
opportunity not really because the the
source material is timeless it's
happening every day and it still
continues to happen but you know this
movie that I just finished comes out
basically a week before Valentine's
dates it's no accident it's a romantic
comedy I like that idea you know it
helps take the movie to a noticeable
level otherwise you're just gonna get in
the mush yeah there's a great story in
the trades about Netflix
buying movies at Sundance last year not
this year last year and it's written by
empathetic filmmakers that said that
here's a movie that is everybody knows
the title everybody would like to see it
but it was on Netflix for one week
on the first page and then it just
disappeared so you have to really know a
lot about the movie properly spell it
and source it and that it's like me I
went last night on Amazon to try to see
if my movie was up for sale because it
just came out and it required me to go
through some closed doors in order to
get there I'm talking about searching
for it because when I typed in the name
it didn't pop right out and there's a
whole nother subject you know naming
your movie
I think distributors would prefer you
name your movie ABCD you know because
it's it's closer to the beginning of the
alphabet
perhaps not anymore because everybody
now is searching for their films and you
just type it in but analytics play a
role now you know you go on to Netflix
are going to Amazon and you you're
trending with romantic comedies they'll
suggest my movie hopefully so that is
you know a plus to them we were making
money and a plus to the distributor
who's making money but all that stuff
never existed I mean the format's of
Netflix and Amazon have changed three
times in the last month meaning how like
right now when you click on a movie on
Amazon a trailer pops up in Netflix too
you know the trailer for anything you're
watching a TV show or whatever while
you're still searching it's playing the
commercial that's all new and innovative
technology and
and it helps the filmmaker but to me
what's really critical is is that if you
know about a filmmaker like me talking
about what I experienced you try to
avoid that with your own experience
so maybe my movie would be called you
know come and eat the food so it's C
rather than an M or maybe it doesn't
matter anymore
I heard you touch on this in another
interview and I'm wondering if you can
elaborate that everything is a cliche
and it's all been done before so how do
we keep films fresh it's it's an
interesting thing because I don't think
a filmmaker sets out to I want to do a
fresh approach to food I want to be a a
fresh approach to a romantic comedy I
think what you do if you're doing a good
service to storytelling is try to do it
with the best experiences that you've
got with the knowledge and knowing that
people don't like to be preached to with
a knowledge and knowing that oh I want
to make a strong female character and
it's written strong but I'd like to make
it even stronger because I'd like her to
make a statement about in this
particular case food and and I also
think you know cliches it's a it's part
of the vernacular of human
communications so it's it's not a bad
thing to make a cliche people have
compared this movie to chef I think who
wouldn't be more flattered than that or
a reviewer just reviewed and and
compared it to chalk a lot chalk a lot
was it was a it was a major influence on
me choosing to make this movie because I
wanted it to be a discovery I wanted it
to be warm I wanted it to be rich and I
wanted it to be real but you know it's
funny there's a there's a there's a TV
show on it on Amazon right now that's
basically a mimic and I'm not going to
tell you the name under the Tuscan Sun
and it's all filmed in Greece and it's
unbelievably magically done it takes
place in the 1930s and I look at that
and I say to myself you know is that a
cliche is that a exploitation not at all
it's just another way to tell the story
is about place I want to go watch that
it's a TV show I want to go watch it
every time I you know I feel certain
need to see the warmth and you know to
be perfectly blunt with you I am NOT an
exterior filmmaker typically so for me
to want to go to New Mexico and exploit
that the biggest compliment you can give
me is comparing it to a movie like
sideways that took parts of Northern
California and made it popular because
the movie was filmed there
I mean Taos I think will be a major
benefactor if the movies successful but
cliches versus remakes how are they
different
I'm saying actually this it's one in the
same because you go out today to make a
remake of you know any of these these TV
shows that are being made now I think
you can temporize it you know and you
try to make it more conducive to what's
going on in the world today and
hopefully try to you know try to do a
better job than the original and it's
interesting because I think that
Hollywood's got a formula for doing that
now and much of it has to do with
bringing in the right writers and the
right directors because it is an art
form and it's failed as much as its
succeeded so cliches you know I think
are just part of the vernacular
someone's always gonna say to you you
know have you seen this it's just like
that I just did it so you know you know
the old story that George Lucas once
would say there's only really seven or
ten stories ever told you know all these
stories have been told before so your
ability to catapult it into a different
look a different drama a different tone
is what makes you know this also
exciting I mean it's funny the movie
that I was about to do was a Holocaust
themed movie but it took place in the in
the 90s and what motivated me to do this
movie is it's not about the Holocaust
and because I didn't want to do a movie
about the Holika I wanted to do a movie
about psychology and about the the
concept of the aftermath of the wall
coming down and that was appealing to me
is it a cliche well if you do what I did
as a filmmaker and looked at everything
that was on either Netflix or Amazon
about these concepts of world war 2 or
even world war 1 you know you walk Oh
with just a you know a huge jar full of
wonderful content and then you say I
don't want to anything like that I want
to use something different
is it a cliche yeah I don't know you
know some people would say it is so a
cliche and then keeping a fresh voice
how does somebody keep a fresh voice we
always hear that you know I been reading
a biography on David Foster Wallace and
how he had this fresh voice at that time
and he was breaking all the rules you
think that could really be done today I
do realize he's I do I do and
essentially because my movie is a
romantic comedy
that takes place surrounding food and
I'm here to tell you with no problem
dropping names because the chef's table
on Netflix is just a brilliantly
produced show I wouldn't want to do it
but I love to watch it and it takes
place all around the world and they
broke all the rules because there's a
million shows about food so why is that
one different because the filmmakers are
great storytellers they take you to the
far corners of a Buddhist monk in South
Korea I mean who would have done that
and they have drones and they have
technology that they're using to make
this just a not only a delightful
one-hour special but you're there you
feel it but isn't it just the same as
what you know well I've been doing this
for so many years I can go back to the
beginning where where they have these
food shows and you got the people Martha
Stewart cooking and and then they show
stills behind her of Tuscany or wherever
the food she's cooking and there's
really no difference in the storytelling
except for for how they went about
executing it